[Music]
long before the birth of light there was
darkness
Jesus you people had an entire two-hour
movie to establish this universe and
you're still opening films with
expositional narration also before there
was light that was darkness on blank
screen cliche such evil was possible
through the power of the ether
the ether will now be the new tesseract
without it the doc how's that lotr MV
buried deep somewhere no one will ever
find it
bury next to that parallax guy just
another day in Disney realm was that an
option this just came out of the smoke
he basically out of nowhere a dude was
rocking off somewhere in the woods and
only came out when things calm down
tesseract terrible weapon for Hydra
minions also serves as great Bifrost
bridge repair kit license ya know I mean
Jane Foster's Jane Foster but SIF is I
mean she's a hot chick who knows how to
fight and wears sexy metal um fits is
there a comparison here Thor returns
from multiple battles and immediately
bathes only his upper half
yeah alcoholism is hilarious especially
while the kid sits on your lap rebound
guy is absolute opposite of dreamy true
love and he's played by Chris O'Dowd
cliche how did none of these orphans
outside ever run into this portal and
for the portal decided to work just now
than we have a sin of plot convenience
I'm sure the movie would later explain
how there happened to be a coincidental
rift in space-time in London for Jane to
fall through that landed her exactly
where the dangerous ether was being in
prison but I'll go ahead out on a limb
now and say that that explanation will
be fucking stupid so this qualifies as
burying something Thor clearly enters
the archway in this shot but then in the
next shot he enters it again despite
being knocked out in another realm
Jane magically transports back to earth
without finding anything that would
bring her back the cops who have been
called to find Jane or apparently not
interested in any capacity to ask her
questions or see if she's okay when she
appears out of nowhere I know I know the
Bifrost was destroyed well let me take
that back the Bifrost was destroyed but
in the first movie we found out that you
didn't really need it to travel between
realms anyway because I came down here
during all that stuff that happened in
the Avengers because Odin used some dark
in
whatever that means but the point is I
had no time to give you even a courtesy
phone call even during that bullsh war
machine then we used the tesseract power
to rebuild the bridge geez it just
explodes my brain property these are the
most lackadaisical cops in history they
just let Jane and Darcy run around out
of you when they intended to arrest them
she does not belong here and as God any
more than a goat belongs in a banquet
table don't some cultures have banquets
where the goat would be the main course
then Thor proceeds to touch her without
a problem and by the way I know some of
you out there are gonna say well it's
because they either knows when the
person touching her is threatening and
when they're not and that's bull because
why would the either even care as long
as it gets to stay in the body
someone just grabbing her shouldn't be a
big deal but the movie says it is and
now Thor can just touch her whenever he
feels like it
convenience Elves reigned absolute
nonchalant couldn't you have just
included this with the big expositional
opening do we really need to separate
history lessons about the ether and the
Dark Elves and this one movie we
interrupt this superhero movie to bring
you prometheus that's racist this is a
clever plan the Dark Elves are hatching
to have this cursed dude get captured
and Trojan horse into the Asgard prison
but how did the dark elves know there
was a war going on they've been sleeping
for thousands of years and all the
sudden they know for a fact that a scar
is fighting to keep the nine realms in
order
why can't hind I'll see that this is a
brand new person he's never seen before
in fact why can t see all those dark
elves that awakened earlier he can see
trillions of souls in the realms
aligning but when a species long thought
dead reappear he goes blind not my
father cliche okay so now I'm having
Anakin and Padme love-story flashbacks
from attack of the clones every five
thousand years the world's align
perfectly and we call this the
convergence during this time the borders
between worlds become blood it's
possible you found one of these points
is it because I thought the convergence
hadn't actually happened yet Thor
himself acknowledged this to Heimdall it
approaches doesn't it and the Dark Elves
talked about it as a future event their
faiths ago
so it hasn't happened yet and therefore
jeans should not have found that portal
also I told you the explanation was
gonna be bull s father did you hear him
say that all the way back there he was
using his quiet I just kissed you voice
to Asgard doesn't inspect prisoners for
weapons or recently opened wounds before
checking them into prison did they not
see the Dark Knight I suppose this
assholes gonna start saying his stomach
hurts now right so the Dark Elves are
using Killians extremists then this
Marvel so dried up creatively that they
can't think of any mysterious deadly
superpowers besides red burning flesh I
need you to do everything I almost got
no questions yes ma'am
Ruby steals dialog straight from my
Natalie Portman fanfiction without
crediting me what purpose does it serve
that the ship becomes visible when it's
touched Heimdall Sauron can just tear
this magic ship apart also ship has a
video game weak spot I was there even
one invisible ship leading the charge
before you just wanted to have a cool
action scene with Heimdall didn't you we
interrupt the superhero movie to bring
you the battle for Naboo
it seems like this could have been done
sooner but oh well the ship actually
drops its trajectory to hit the force
field the mother did he know to come
here
I guarantee you it wasn't that bullet
with Loki who told him to take the
stairs to the left you might want to
take the stairs to the left and even if
taking the stairs to the left directed
him here he had no idea before he came
down that there was a force field
surrounding the castle so how would he
know that destroying this thing would in
any way be worth his time Heimdall sword
can pick up a ship pretty quick but all
the columns and Asgard's Castle do no
damage to a ship at all the straight
hole somehow remains standing even after
all the support columns are wiped out by
the crashing alien ship wait Malekith
was on that ship that kamikaze crashed
into the Great Hall that was pretty
fuckin stupid given what we've seen
lasers and Heimdall sword due to these
ships earlier sure we get a cool villain
entrance moment but the actual plan took
logic and threw it out the window
thanks Odin you came just in time we
were here a second ago in the dark elves
were kicking all the assets now it looks
like everyone's dead for no reason who
are you yeah Doctor Who is that okay so
she's a hologram so can her real
physical self wherever it is see
everything that's going on where she
controlling herself with a joystick or
Kinect or something complete with the
heads-up display or is free jizz
illusion so strong that it pretends to
move around and look worried and where
is the ephah you're drawn to it remember
the fifty you need a verbal answer for
so this ship knew that these guys were
gonna get knocked off this very balcony
to be waiting for them can come on
okay sure it disappeared but the hammer
is still headed in that direction right
as we saw with Heimdall earlier these
invisible ships still have mass and can
be destroyed and seriously all of this
magic and they can't solve one sword
stabbed in the back
if this had been thor odin's it would
have had some sort of a lik search ant
or moon do to bring them back to life
spirit dust me we interrupt this
superhero movie to bring you tangled we
don't see who the person is talking to
because it's probably an empty room or
not the expected audience cliche at some
point we pass from honoring the Marvel
creator into territory where we're just
humoring a senile old man who actually
kills suspension of disbelief in every
single Marvel movie right I mean I think
we're already there but maybe that's
just me a terrible bad guy conveniently
needs some R&R so that the rest of the
plot has time to happen before the big
finale my king we are all but
defenseless well I'm sure I mean man
Hulk and all those other Avenger dudes
could handle it I mean have you thought
about giving them a call come to us
destroy he will I am still confused as
to how much power these Dark Elves have
between all the ass-kicking as guardians
Odin staff and Thor's hammer plus the
mysterious fate of all the other Dark
Elves who were kicking ass and then were
suddenly dead I don't think they pose
much of a challenge really plus the
tesseract can kill or fix anything so
[Music]
Selvig honestly they didn't even need to
rehash dr. Selvig streaking at
Stonehenge we already saw this earlier
in the movie so Darcy should have been
able to figure out that he was in the
psych ward and we maybe could have just
cut straight to her trying to get him
out the Bifrost is closed by your
father's orders no one is to come let's
go well that worked so well in the last
movie Catelyn overrule my Kings wishes
not even for you I'm not asking you to
all right Thor has a plan that won't get
Heimdall in trouble reason my lord fine
Jesus I mean what a liar Thor is what
I'm about to ask of you is treason of
the highest order also this is the exact
same scenario from the first movie the
cop Thor banned earth in the first place
he went somewhere he wasn't supposed to
go to fight a guy he'd been told not to
fight after his father had ordered the
Bifrost closed
you're not even trying anymore I sure am
glad SIF turned around for no reason at
all so that we can see who one of the
Clos
people is Malekith new the youth Lucia
he consents its power except for when
the plot called for him not to sense the
ether and he reached for a fucking
illusion this is the movies way of
saying we could have put the Avengers in
this movie he just didn't oh and
costumes be much also why did Thor and
Loki keep their exact voice no matter
who they changed into until Loki turned
into Captain America what did they not
hear all this commotion in an empty
large hallway and now this is a love
triangle I'd like to be the hypotenuse
in I need it's a UNIX system you know
that right sure let's just get on the
alien ship power it up and fly away
[Music]
alright now that we've randomly powered
it up let's become experts at flying in
the next five seconds I really don't
think there were any columns left to
destroy it for the first time but the
movie ensures that there are because
destruction know when chasing Thor sees
bodies flying out of the ship nice trick
but you were flying that thing wildly
all over the place so how did this
secret ship keep up with all that
madness you have to know the altitude
the speed in the exact distance the
secret ship has to be behind the dark
elf ship in order to catch anyone damn
there's not even anyone in this ship
anymore and they can't shoot it down
with a hail of sci-fi lasers really only
one ship and if Thorin crew were so
easily detected after they jumped off
the Dark Elf ship and why did they even
bother going through flying that ship in
the first place attacking ship decides
to stop shooting while Fandral does this
again I don't know how you do this
the ship was behind you now it just
happens to be in perfect rope swinging
distance and not one asshole sees this
coming for some reason also if this ship
can barely make it through the tunnel
then why did Loki never object to flying
on the dark elf ship he didn't know the
plan Thor tricked him never once did he
say hey man this big-ass ship this ship
won't make it through the secret pathway
this plan will not work unless you get
me on a smaller ship you really asked
are they
join you in a hotter way this can't be a
trick at all we interrupt this superhero
movie to bring you star trek into
darkness and does Loki's secret pathway
only come here
are there other realms that you can
enter through that passage in the
mountains or just this one because I
mean what a stroke of luck that the one
secret passage in the entire kingdom can
come to the exact spot Thor needed to
take Jane don't have to sign for your
father's really a plan just say you're
someone's kid and break a guy out of a
psych ward well he broke you out of the
mental hospital just in time then Thor
too borrows the scientists problems
estimating time thing from 2012 see the
birds were just waiting for the actors
to get on their marks before reappearing
Darcy forgets that she saw this same
phenomenon a couple days ago we
interrupt this superhero movie to bring
you looper oh come on we've seen these
things work remember they did not have
some sort of artificial delay and
sending people through their doom and
disability is totally necessary right
now there's Thor's invincible hammer
completely waffling again on how
powerful it is none of this would have
happened if I hadn't found the aether
Malekith would have only possessed it
that much sooner how would he have
possessed it sooner this is amazing okay
great the planets of a line cellphones
from Earth can call the dark realm but
man you're in a mother concave the next
thing you'll tell me is that they found
Spock in this cave even convenience's
angry at this kind of plot convenience
why would the portal take them here
shouldn't it be in that stairway where
the kids were throwing all that down in
it also why did anything they throw down
into that thing ever come back if it
went into the cave there doesn't appear
to be any other portal it could have
fallen into to come back unless it
boomerang back into the portal it came
from but then it shouldn't have come out
of the sky but the portal at the bottom
of the stairs
they didn't oh this thing out of here
they towed that huge truck that was on
its side but the station wagon of the
girl who flew out of Earth of Thor let's
just keep that here forgive me my liege
okay so we know this is Loki posing as a
soldier so how did he get back to Asgard
can he fly so fast that he made it
through the tunnel and if he used his
nebulous dark magic then why does he
ever need to use the secret passageway
to come and go from Asgard
fire the ether at a spot where all the
nine worlds are connecting good thing
the weapon she had inside her told we're
all about the plan of the bad guy who
was merely planning to use the weapon
all the great constructions the Mayans
the Chinese the Egyptians and then left
us a map a map that can be deciphered
entirely in the United Kingdom these are
all coordinates taking us here the line
sell the drew were all arbitrary I mean
I could take all these points and make
the lines pass through somewhere else if
I wanted to and wouldn't this obsess
doctor or figured this out already yeah
Greenwich you that's only a short drive
from where we are now sure dodged a
bullet on that one library Nazi
super-powerful ether that has no equal
does a good job knocking Thor down but
that's about it these devices were made
to detect anomalies not caused them are
you kidding me with that sure this
unpredictable convergence can be
harnessed to transport assholes anywhere
you need them to go all you need is a
thing and a few other things Man of
Steel itis portals just happened to be
anywhere everywhere and nowhere all at
once this would be fun if there was any
actual logic to it now they just show up
at the ice giant place after going back
and forth between earth and the dark
world the entire time we interrupt this
superhero movie to bring you Harry
Potter I mean technically speaking
wouldn't the crisis here the Thor's
facing be more important than the one
Ironman faced in Iron Man 3 should an
Iron Man be here helping Thor I mean if
Killian wins he just has a bunch of
super soldiers and robots but he hasn't
started a war yet he doesn't threaten to
delete the entire universe as Malekith
does priority wise the Avengers are all
out of whack
Wolfe overload so Malekith fell on his
face and went boom and that's supposed
to give me satisfaction can he just get
up and keep using the ether to be a dick
isn't the ether still out there and
dangerous now did any thought go into
this script after the first draft I
guess Odin's dead now what a battle that
must have been oh well we didn't need to
see it I guess and credits scene
introduces another bull artifact that
we're gonna have to worry about in
future movies and we'll have vague but
extreme power one
down five to go oh there's six of these
gun things and this guy's collecting
them damn it all so he's had a plan to
get these Infinity stones in the first
one he captures is willingly given to
him he's been sitting around hoping
someone would give him one so he could
start looking for the others damn you
Avengers now there has to be two bullet
scenes at the end of every Marvel movie
she will not survive the amount of
energy
[Music]
we outfitted our fastest ship using red
matter I would create a black hole which
would absorb the exploding star I was on
really when the unthinkable happened
the supernova destroyed Romulus
[Music]
see you managed to get your shirt off